hello-oh flashing lights black and white
Oh
what is this hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to exposure oh
hello
oh okay oh this is me oh oh this is the
weirdest thing okay interact sorry oh my
new apartment I've barely started to
unpack apparently there's a door that is
still locked but the keys should be
around here somewhere okay I know how
this goes
I should not open that door it's going
to kill me that's how this goes I know
this I know this for a fact I know this
very well
okay well let's get to it glad this is a
brutal err which style documentary of
everything that's got horrible in my
life oh my god oh my god I'm sorry if
this is incredibly disorienting but I
kind of like it I kind of love it
hello hi oh why is it so dark in my
goddamn apartment why do I have a fish
love fisheye lens what is this a work
lamp is that all I have oh hello hi okay
alright then
oh it's dark in here okay oh man I do
not like this oh hello
okey great okay [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that it seems that there's a mirror
missing at the table where I found the
key okay alright there's a mirror miss
oh god not going in there holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah what is you it's a bathroom
bath [ __ ]
everything looks terrifying in the dark
yeah oh god this game is giving me the
heebie-jeebies Oh incredibly I'm not
going in there yet ye it's a mere
missing was there a mirror there before
well that's getting that's getting
really it's really fuzzy when I look
maybe it's always that way okay here we
go hi oh boy this looks bad oh hi Heidi
Heidi Heidi ho oh why the [ __ ] is this
here okay you know what okay all right I
know what to do
yeah why where did where did
why would I do that I'm in a building in
New York they're probably old it would
probably collapse the son of a [ __ ]
this is hidden area behind the room but
that's not possible this floor is full
of apartments yeah yeah not possible
haha definitely not possible
Oh oh boy
why do I have to go back what do I keep
going hi okay I'm a brave boy I'll press
forward oh god oh god oh god I don't
like this oh it's the bye bye man what
is this wait a minute that's not right
eyes are like an outline of a mirror
there [ __ ] is that sound oh this is some
found-footage craziness alright fine I'm
gonna go into the darkness and I'm not
gonna turn around it's good press on
here we go okay
okay III don't know what I'm looking for
Oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] what is
this what is this Oh God
I can't tell where I am Oh God what's
that there's something there okay
all right whoa oh no I gotta feel my way
around the walls
I hate this oh whoa what the [ __ ] is
that what the [ __ ] is that
oh okay I thought it was oh it's door
okay this door in here I found one okay
hello hi oh god damn it
[ __ ] hell I found a locked gate at
the end of the hall since I broke the
wall I won't stop now what you kind of
did to come back here for whatever
[ __ ] reason okay just gonna carry on
I grab the sledgehammer and I just keep
going I guess just keep going I guess
going I guess oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy okay the [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is bad
okay then gate is open now how do you
know what is the gate - is it a gate to
hell
T to heaven oh it's a lot of noise
happening like this
I don't like that bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
where am I
what what
yeah
bleki what the [ __ ] bye who are you go
[ __ ] yourself
what do you got there camera so do i
[ __ ] you you are soulless [ __ ] [ __ ] off
oh god oh god oh god okay I'm going I'm
gone I'm gone baby I'm gone
there's the game gate is open now
we're here yes well [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
I guess I just sit here and wait calmly
for my death to arrive I see you there
oh you're coming wait
oh no you only walk when I do whoa
what the [ __ ] Oh what the hell what the
hell what
ji-hye
okay
okay oh that's the end oh great
wonderful oh boy hey boy I feel horrible
I feel uncomfortable I feel like I've
been horrifically violated yeah so I
think that's the end yep seems like it
so that was exposure holy [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] terrifying had no idea what was
happening and it did a lot with very
little like the UH the VHS recording
aspect of it made it made like the flaws
of the the low graphics like not seem
apparent it was just man those [ __ ]
terrifying
I don't know what it means I have no
idea what it means but you guys can
interpret it for what you will so wow if
you want to try this game out I'll put a
link in the description below and to the
developer you got a knack for this stuff
buddy you got a knack you got a good
knack for it so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down the comments below
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]